demon souls is all about close calls and
they feel a hell of a lot closer with
the dual sense in hand
[Music]
by now you've probably heard all about
the dual sense its adaptive triggers add
tension to r2 and l2 and its haptic
feedback adds a bit of nuance to your
classic controller rumble
by and large these features are great
while they haven't fundamentally changed
the way games are played they can lead
to some very clever ideas
especially when it comes to shooters as
our very own john luke pointed out in
his video about call of duty black ops
cold war
however my favorite showcase for the
dual sense so far is blue points demon
souls remake
rather than making any sweeping gameplay
changes to from software's masterpiece
bluepoint uses the dual sense to
accentuate action
nearly every action you take in the game
is reflected with haptic
feedback that's a fancy way of saying
that rolling through barrels and
smashing barricades feels
even better with the dual senses
context-specific rumbles
but it extends far beyond my systematic
destruction of every single wooden
object in demon souls
whisking through a fog door before
taking on a hulking boss yields a soft
rumble a near deadly fall could send a
powerful jolt through the controller
and a ferocious dragon soaring overhead
at breakneck speeds will make the dual
sense
shudder in your hands combat in
particular feels heightened thanks to
the haptic feedback
connecting blows with a weapon whether
that be the formidable bastard sword or
your bare fists will elicit a different
rumble depending on the surface you hit
and where your weapon connects the wear
in this context
may seem a bit strange but it makes
sense when you think of the rumble as
you would stereo audio
if you hit an object or enemy slightly
to your right the rumble will be more
prominent on the right side of the dual
sense
if you thrust your weapon the rumble
will feel centralized
just like stereo audio the positioning
and source can affect the rumble
for example if i slash this brick wall
from this position i will feel a
sharp quick rumble in the right side of
the controller as my sword bounces off
the hard surface
if i face the other direction in swing i
feel a longer vibration in the left side
of the dual sense that mimics how my
character dragged his sword across the
wall at the end of the swing
sure it's minor but it makes your
weapons feel heftier and deadlier thanks
to that extra bit of precise feedback
the dual sense provides
this is even more true when it comes to
backstabs parries and reposts
if you've played a souls game before
then you know how satisfying a
successful parian rapost
is
in the demon souls remake your
character's actions are given a
wonderfully distinct pattern that
matches the animation
every time you pull one off i've put
myself in harm's way
far too many times just to pull off one
of these slick counters
also while we're here let's give a quick
shout out to the unarmed riposte
because frankly it might just be the
most satisfying animation of 2020
but let's be honest you will undoubtedly
spend a lot of time taking blows and
hiding behind a shield
this is demon souls after all of course
the dual sense accounts for this as well
attacks that bounce off your shield
yield a single soft and confident rumble
the haptic feedback is amplified when
your guard breaks
leaving you open to direct attacks
however my favorite use of the haptics
has to be the spells
so if you need a good excuse to play
easy mode hear me out
just like weapons each spell is given a
different vibration pattern that's
mirrored with the animation
for example flame toss starts with a
subtle vibration that builds as if your
character is drawing power from within
themselves
until they've mustered up the energy to
unleash a ball of fire from their
catalyst
at which point the dual sense gives off
an explosive vibration
if the spell hits a nearby enemy a final
explosive rumble will shake the dual
sense
i've never shot a fireball out of a wand
in real life but i imagine it probably
would feel something like this
alternatively if you cast something like
water veil the results will be
appropriately more subtle the dual sense
will vibrate as you cast it as long as
its effects are active you will feel a
slight consistent rumble until the spell
wears off
aside from just feeling pretty cool this
is a handy way to know when a buff
expires and it's time to recast it
these examples taken alone may seem
small but as a whole they make
bulletaria
feel more alive obviously the game looks
and sounds incredible but the dual sense
gives the world a tactile feel that up
until now has only been explored with
rudimentary rumble features
it's particularly powerful in demon
souls because the game is so harrowing
as
is the moments i look back fondly on and
want to share with my friends
are the ones where i barely scrape by
whether it's delivering the final blow
to a boss with only a sliver of health
or
narrowly dodging a fireball in a room
full of explosive barrels
when you add in the precise and
deliberate feedback of the controller
these moments feel even more palpable
those deadly encounters feel
deadlier which means when you overcome
them they feel all the more satisfying
[Music]
you